استكمالا لملف الحرب في اوكرانيا روسيا
تفوض الصين بشان تزويدها بطائرات من دون
طيار باستخدامها او لاستخدامها في حربها
في اوكرانيا وفق ما كشفته مجله الالمانيه
وطلبت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انتاج
واختبارا مئه نموذج اولي من الطائرات من
دون طيار زدتي 180 على ان تكون قادره على
حمل راس حربي وتسليمها لموسكو بحلول
ابريلال المقبل المجله الالمانيه كشفت
ايضا ان تصميم المسيرات سيكون مشابها
للمسيرات الايرانيه شاهد 136 التي
تستخدمها موسكو في حربها على اوكرانيا
مسيراته 180 مشاهدينا تساعد موسكو الى حد
كبير ستساعدها بضرب الاهداف الرئيسيه بدقه
عاليه وفق خبراء في النيتو لكن نفت صحه
هذا المطلب الروسي في حين اكدته واشنطن
واعتبرت ان بكين تقدم دعما كبيرا لموسكو
بعد ان اسقطت اوكرانيا مئه المسيرات
الايرانيه
[موسيقى]